check this place out  i'm on an island off another island  very south of iran  in the persian gulf  and  truly a surprise like most of this  country  that's full of contradiction in mystery  and surprises  here i am  and i never thought of iran being some  sort of beach destination  and nobody else really is either because  nobody's here  the iranians  from what i've heard don't like to hang  out at the beaches they like to shop  so  lucky me  i've got this place to myself  and it's almost like a mesa verde  type setting or like a southern utah  type setting  that just drops right into the turquoise  blue waters  very cool to say the least  what else to say country's been awesome  and i am leaving in a few days which is  sad but  it's been an awesome  journey  a  big expansive  mind [ __ ]  in many ways  and  all i can say is i'm happy for today  peace  and right over the strait of hormuz  and to dubai